now to Idaho in the desperate search for
evidence in the murder of those four
college students there was a vigil held
last night in Boise the state capitol
about 300 miles from the scene of the
crime but there's still no suspect not
even a murder weapon but there is now an
official cause of death for the four
friends who were killed in their home
early Sunday for reasons police still
don't understand
Christina raffini has more from Moscow
Idaho
while authorities in Idaho hunt for a
mass murderer a College Community
remains on edge it was nerve-wracking to
hear them say that we are no longer like
totally safe autopsies are the four
young victims have been completed with
hopes of finding DNA evidence of their
killer on their bodies I was shocked
when I got a call for four homicides
Lata County coroner Kathy Mabbitt
declared the victim's manner of death
stabbing likely from a large knife she
told us the case is one of the worst
she's seen they were pretty involved in
the community so it yeah it feels very
personal the victims are seniors Madison
mojen and Kaylee Gonzalez friends from
separate sororities who lived together
for several years Ethan Chapin a
freshman and triplet who loved playing
basketball and his girlfriend Zana
kernodle a junior who majored in
marketing her father Jeffrey who lives
in Arizona told our Phoenix affiliate
that Zanna had bruises on her arms
possibly from fighting off her attacker
she's a tough kid whatever she wanted to
do she could do it investigators are
trying to piece together a timeline
using live stream video of mojin and
gonsalves at a food truck before they
headed back to their off-campus house
police revealed they are working with
the two surviving roommates who were
home during the attack but are not
considered suspects University officials
say they've increased campus patrols and
are excusing all absences if they want
to leave and go home now they absolutely
can we're going to support them in doing
so
Nate we spoke to a neighbor who was here
at the time of the incident we asked did
he hear anything and he said you know
what no but this is a college town
There's a fraternity house across the
street It's Not Unusual to hear shouts
and yelling and parties and Loud things
on a Saturday night they didn't realize
anything had happened until the next
morning when they saw the cop cars in
front of the house now the FBI
Behavioral analysis team is also here
helping local law enforcement but we're
waiting for the results of that
toxicology report to see what state the
victims were in when they died
still so many questions Christina thank
you